never in my life has there been have I
had more sex in my life than with my
wife wants another child how's that
going for you I've never met your one
look I mean I just wanna be great though
I mean I'll use you she's a great say
you seem to be in a great mood all the
time every time I was well yes please
tell us that I will tell you so ha ha
there a lot of information cause a lot
of it wasn't it a lot of it that's how
you that's how you get good answers are
you ready for war yeah I mean again I
think that a lot of has to do with a
being with the right first one that also
with I think we did a humdinger of a job
on the one we got and now the Jen and
Justin have finally tied the knot
I was curious where she stands on
motherhood have you reached that point
in your life where you're at peace you
know as we get older we come to this
point where like I'm at peace with my
life I'm happy yeah I'm very peaceful
I feel very peaceful I literally think
that every day like wake up and feel
very lucky I feel very fortunate yeah I
got a good one I got a sweet kind man
yeah yeah
sucks likes talented oh I know right
that's annoying for other guys like he
looks good then he's actually good at
what he does but you deserve it so thank
you hey you know no junk food for
breakfast had lets us he also lets you
go to school without any underwear in
the film Jen plays a single mother
coming to terms with divorce and David
daughter yeah - same boat two sons nice
meeting you sandy with two sons you guys
have done 107 movies together
so not all them are released we want to
release fun that's what I say who it
okay so who's carrying who who would who
get two sides to deal first all the time
he's on my tails yeah Coleman assume I'm
a contract after five films together
Jason is obviously a fan but Jen seems
to have that effect on her co-stars just
ask Jake Gyllenhaal who started with
Jenn in the good girl back in 2002 Jake
Gyllenhaal came out he said he had a
huge crush on you
we're doing that information now what
you what bran does it to me now love
that boy
you